[Musique]
je cherche une auberge de jeunesse ah
ouais d'accord je vois j'en connais une
dans le coin je veux dire même
pris mon sac on peut remplacer ce qui a
été volé alors que le corps lui on ne
répare pas si facilement vous pourriez
peut-être m'aider je suis venu à Hong
Kong pour participer au comité j'avais
demandé un dragon et toi tu m'envoies
une Barbie
je vais t'entraîner pour un tournoi
à l'issue duquel tu seras soit très
riche sois très abîmé tu passeras trois
mois ici avec moi à t'entraîner je
resterai le temps qu'il faudra pour
apprendre à faire ça
tout ce que nous demandons ce sont des
combats équitable à chaque round jusqu'à
la finale
le parfum de la douleur bienvenue au
comité
[Musique]
vous croyez que l'américaine ira en
finale
[Musique]
ton maître pense que tu maîtrises
parfaitement le Wu-Tang je vais lui
montrer qu'elle se trompe montre le moi
maintenant